we have any clashes I think sometimes
the the terms that are used can make a
situation look aggravated when in fact
it isn't but it is a fact that India's
neighborhood is in turmoil you have had
you know the elections in Nepal in which
the Communist Party came out on top they
are still trying to form a government
you have bhutan which is of course a
wonderful example where the King has
himself assured in democracy and stood
aside in favor of his son so that they
can be a good transition you have
Bangladesh where there is a government
which came in after removing both the
civilian political parties you have Sri
Lanka which is still in turmoil you had
an election in Pakistan in which
unfortunately the leader of one of the
main political parties was assassinated
before the elections you have all the
problems that are in the newspapers
every day in Afghanistan which is one of
our near neighbours so we do live in a
neighborhood which is in turmoil but
none of these problems and none of these
governments are at odds with the
Government of India so we hope that the
political transitions that are underway
around us will resolve themselves
peacefully and will resolve themselves
quickly but there aren't any clashes in
fact the heads of government of all the
sarc countries the south asian regional
cooperation are meeting in Colombo even
as we speak and they have come to a
number of agreements on how to proceed
with